1989 was not a great year for communism
all across the Eastern Bloc the
communist outer Empire collapsed
suddenly under a wave of nationalism
economic grievance and a sympathy for
the Western Way of life Romania or
officially the Socialist Republic of
Romania was not spared this revolution
and in 1989 it saw the collapse of the
regime there under the leadership of
Nicolae Ceausescu now despite being part
of the communist bloc and for all
intents and purposes the Soviet puppet
state Romania was a slightly different
case you see it had a much greater
degree of independence from the Soviet
Union then say Poland or Bulgaria this
was down to the policy of national
communism which spoke of how Romania was
historically unified by fighting against
foreign invaders
this made the Soviet Union nervous since
they expected that any intervention
would be very costly in terms of lives
also to make things worse chess q lay
claim to the Moldavian Soviet Socialist
Republic as a rightful part of Romania
now the USSR never did anything because
one Romania developed extremely good
relations with the US and the USSR
didn't want a major international
incident again and to communism in
Romania wasn't actually under threat and
so the USSR assumed that it simply
needed to outlive Ceausescu for
relations to be restored this political
semi separation from the USSR didn't
stop the tide of anti-communist feeling
and sure enough it swept across Romania
too much of it was down to declining
living standards throughout the 1980s
which was caused by church SQ tightening
the purse strings after the country had
racked up immense debts in the 70s as
revolution swept across the Eastern Bloc
many communist leaders recognized
eventually that the game was up and they
implemented a period of transition to
democratic capitalism the two nations
which did not do this were Bulgaria and
Romania you see Church sq believed he
had a way to contain this public
discontent and to do this year a clever
tactic shooting protesters or
specifically having Eleanor his wife and
number two in control of the country or
during the shooting of dissenters in the
city of Timmins awara on December the
21st 1989 Ceausescu gave his speech to a
huge crowd of communist supporters in
order to denounce the protesters one
problem everyone hated him and the crowd
started to boo him and given that this
speech was televised it confirmed to
everyone else in the country how
unpopular the leadership was protest
soon spread across the country in the
next day the church s Jews fled
Bucharest and immediately after this a
provisional government the National
Salvation Front was formed with yoni Li
s cous
seating chart Chesky was president
Alaska was also a communist but he was
critical of Ceausescu in the past and so
had been sidelined and thus was distant
enough from the regime to get the job on
the 24th of December the church s cues
were captured and handed over to the
Army in the next day they were put on
trial for their past actions
now this trial didn't have time for
silly little things like evidence and
Loy's and was frankly little more than a
sham in a verdict that shocked everyone
the couple were found guilty and
sentenced to spend the rest of their
lives in custody
which was literally five minutes because
they were actually sentenced to death
which was to be carried out immediately
at first illy ESCO attempted to maintain
a communist government claiming that the
people had revolted against Ceausescu
but actually like communism
this was not an opinion shared by many
Romanians and protests and violence
continued even after this
illy escu conceded and in 1990 he was
elected with an overwhelming mandate and
he began the process of moving Romania
away from communism to a market economy
remaining his revolution is different to
the other Eastern European ones in a
simple but important way whilst Romania
was no longer a communist country those
who had been in the Communist Party were
still running it I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching but
thanks to my patreon supporters whom you
can see on screen now and with an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette Ike
Danny Maloney Colin Castleman Marvin
Castle Rob Waterhouse Aaron the white
Jordan long way Chris wicker Gustav Swan
Gareth Turner Marcus oz nur Maggie pax
Kowski David Silverman spinning three
plates
Spencer Lightfoot Lexi Schwinn Winston
k-word Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett the original cage Robert
Wetzel Skye Chappell par shoe 19 and Moe